you remember meeting me do you remember
how we met 100
do you remember i i do but i would love
to hear how you remember it and then
i'll tell you how i remember it
okay you want me to go first or you want
to go first i'll go first all right if
if i may
it's your show dude okay thank you all
right so um
it was at the 101 cafe
yes okay i was sitting there by myself
because i lived on beechwood so i used
to go there all the time
it was late at night and from my
peripheral vision
i see and i don't take this the wrong
way a korean warlock
i don't think that the wrong way it was
you were dressed in some sort of garb
it wasn't like human clothing like
american human clothing it was like a
gala
it was like a fiesta right but from the
future and the past it was crazy
yeah it was like he was wearing stuff
and right i mean you weren't
there was a poncho for sure there were
just things going on
you probably weren't wearing any shoes
nail polish and for my periphery i go
am i imagining this and then i kind of
looked and i got no and also i
know who that is yeah immediately i knew
who that was oh [ __ ] that's david cho he
can do dresses the way he wants to dress
right because if you were like a
gardener it'd be weird but you know
that'd be dope actually that would be
dope you're right so um
and then you came up to me yeah you came
up to me
and i think you put your arms around me
yeah one arm and you go hey man do you
know who i am
i think that's oh no no you said
hey bro i'm a fan of yours and then i go
oh [ __ ] me too i'm a fan yeah
and then you sat next to me and i
remember i was soaking wet
yeah you were wet i was soaking wet my i
was wearing a suit
yeah much like this one but you weren't
wearing other garb my brother had just
gotten married
uh two hours ago earlier and it was one
of those parties where everyone threw
each other in the pool
so i was with my brother and and my
friend harry
and we were all wet and it was like my
brother just got married
it was late let's go eat again after
eating birthday you weren't wearing any
other outfit i'm sure i threw a poncho
over the wall oh go go go go go
i don't have something going on i was
wearing something i'm sure okay
and um so i'm sitting uncomfortable in
wet clothes and a poncho
and um don't take this the wrong way
okay don't open don't take this the
wrong here's what i hate when people do
that
here just real quick okay a korean
warlock walks in
a correct look there's no
there's no it's like we're sitting there
eating we're
at a restaurant i'm walking in now in
the story
he walks in yeah sucks up all the air
and french fry juice in the in the room
[Laughter]
i'm like not only not only do i know who
this guy is
everybody knows who this guy is you're
talking to all the waitresses
it's it's like this is a visual that i
have you have a visual of
asian warlock wearing nail polish in a
poncho which may or may not i can't
confirm that
i have a visual of you with your hands
up like this
like i'm like this guy yeah is fearless
i don't know if he knows those people at
that table
you are you are holding court at cafe
101.
i'm like this guy does not and then of
course
different time different rules a nutsac
is out
so i see i don't even know wait wait
stop wait
real quick time different rules
different time different rules different
time different rules can i say this
one ball one ball i don't all right i'm
gonna keep my voice
down not two balls from where i was i
could see it was one ball don't open up
relationships with my sack out i don't
do a sack attack
i don't think you knew who these people
were at this table there was a caesar
salad there was
i walked up to a random table with my
sack out you were you were loud
i was like you were very comfortable it
was like you were at a comedy club
you were you were joking with people you
knew and as you were being loud people
were like hey bobby lee and you would
just go over there oh hold on you were
like
but it was your neighborhood yeah it's
your hood you it was i had been there
for decades i have a very clear vis i
could paint it right now yeah
of you standing at the edge of a table
one one of your balls
is at the edge of the table and some
people are
dying salad dressing coming out they're
laughing and yeah
you couldn't be at more home yeah you
didn't you the ball thing
don't defend it just it was it just okay
and and what am i doing where i'm
sitting
i'm done i'm like i've never met bobby
lee
and this is what i imagine he would be
like he's here just
and and normally when i meet celebrities
or i see celebrities out in the wild i
don't approach them i go there's that
guy and i just
i don't say anything and i said this guy
seems approachable
[Laughter]
i don't go up to someone and put my arm
around them like all right
and i see him and i go he's talking to
everybody
yeah so i'm gonna like i don't know if
i'm ever gonna meet bobby lee again
i'm gonna try well not only did we meet
davey right if i can call you that you
can call me whatever you want okay
um not only do you can call me whatever
you want robert go ahead
oh my god please don't bow again
but there was a second though admitted
that we were going to
yeah yeah yeah i know i melted your eyes
yeah i felt
like i felt me going forward but then
you stopped it thank you so much
because i don't want to go down i sat
there with my brother and inside i felt
this guy is very unsafe this is an
unsafe person like
he is making because i don't know what's
coming next
yeah we're just sitting here eating our
chicken and waffles whatever
and he comes in like the tasmanian devil
he starts eating people's french fries
nut sacks are out
and i go i don't know what this guy's
gonna do next one one nut is out
i don't know what he's gonna do next and
so of course i'm attracted to that
i know you are so i go closer to you
instead of being like that guy's
dangerous i should go away from that guy
i put my arm around you
yeah like a moth to the flame well it's
like you ever see mad max
not the new one but the old ones and
that
one you know that big gigantic guy but
then he has that little guy
the master blaster right right that it's
almost as if
i'm that little guy you're the big guy
and we were separated
40 years ago hear me or whatever and
it's like i like that hey
you know what i mean let me get on your
back it was as if
we always knew each other and we could
do this thing where it's about race
you're this kind of korean or that kind
of asian filipino mexican whatever
yeah but in this life
yeah that's it yeah that's it that's it
who am i i'm the little guy right no i'm
the little guy you just called me a
hobbit earlier
how the [ __ ] are you you're the big guy
you're the king you're the king
don't do it don't do it don't do it no
i knew
fat dude oh my god
yeah he can't do that
he's a lot heavier than he looks dave
i'd be careful